Hello world,
it's Saroj and today we're going to
learn how to prepare a dataset before
feeding it into a machine learning model
or example code will predict if someone
is meditating or not by training
on a Dataset of brain scans.
Data is raw information.
It's a representation of both human
and machine observations of the world.
Everything can be represented as
data, all science, art, literature,
all of it can be represented as
ones and Zeros on a computer.
When we enter a virtual world,
we are literally surrounded by data.
Since it is the fundamental building
block of everything we see and when we
observe something physical in real life,
it becomes data in our brain.
Unless our universe is a simulation,
then everything you see is already data.
If you don't work at a tech giant,
how are you supposed to get that data?
That brings us to step
one in preparing data,
deciding the right kind of data to use
that data set you use entirely depends on
the problem you're trying to solve.
If I want to build a chat bot that comes
up with new innovative product ideas,
I'm not going to use a
Dataset of Tim Cook Dialogue.
Data is a means to an end and the good
news is there is a public dataset for
almost any topic.
You can think about a couple of sites
I like to use to find cool datasets are
Kaggle since I love the format of their
website and how they explain each of
their datasets in detail.
Also,
the datasets subreddit is great for
requesting datasets you want and there is
this awesome list of public datasets in
the read me of this get hub repo that
I'll link to in the description.
Google's advanced search
feature is also super helpful.
Usually combining a few keywords with
the word data or database is enough to
find what we need and to make it easier.
We can specify the type of file we want
like CSP and the type of domain like edu
or Gov.
Usually a website has an API that makes
it easier to get the data you need,
but if it doesn't,
you can use a library like beautiful
soup to take a raw html webpage and just
scrape the data directly.
Diy data died. No.
Once we decided the type of data we want,
our second step is to process it.
We're going to write a function to
extract data from a brain scan data set.
Then we can feed that
data into a single layer.
Neural network created intenser flow,
the network.
We'll create a separator line between
two classes so that given a new person's
brain scan data, it can predict
if they are meditating or not.
Let's take a look at this data.
This is a list of neurological metrics
collected via an EEG device for a set of
human volunteers.
There are two possible classes,
either meditating represented by a one
or not meditating represented by a zero,
and there are three features for
this data. A measure of mental focus,
a measure of calmness and the volunteers
age want to format our data properly.
Data could come in the form of a text
file or a relational database or like,
well, we have a CSV and there's a library
to convert pretty much any file type to
another.
So make sure you have your data,
format it to a file type that
you most feel comfortable with.
Once it's in the right format,
we'll want to clean the data.
Sometimes we have instances in
our data that are incomplete.
We can iterate through each row and
delete those instances by checking if the
value is empty or not. We should
also decide what features to use.
Deciding what features are important is
one of the key parts of data science.
If we don't use the right features,
our model will make bad predictions.
We only want to use features
that are relevant to our problem.
Their gender has nothing to do
with their meditative state,
so we can totally disregard that feature.
So let's first create two arrays.
One Array, we'll hold our class labels.
The other array, we'll hold our features.
We can iterate through every line in
our CSV file. Using this for loop.
We'll define a row which is a single
instance as an array of values.
By splitting the line by the
comma separator. Using this row,
we can first get the associated class
label by retrieving the first value in our
row array, converting it to an end
than adding it to our labels array.
Now we can do the same thing
for our features are ray.
We'll take each feature
and convert it to a float.
Since we want precision in our values,
our feature array is
now an array of arrays.
Now that we've pulled our data
from our dataset file into memory,
we've arrived at the last
step transforming the data.
One possible transformation
is decomposition.
Sometimes we have features that
are too complex like the date.
If we're trying to predict which day in
October is most likely to get rainfall
this year, we don't really
need the month and the year.
If we decompose that feature
into just the day of the month,
that'll make our model more accurate.
Since we're satisfied with the
features we have in their class,
labels will perform.
The only transformation we need
will transform them into vectors.
Vectors are numerical
representations of features.
All features can be represented
as vectors, words, images, videos,
all of it. We can take these vectors and
feed them into our neural net directly.
We'll convert our array of arrays into
a two d matrix using numb Pi's matrix
function and set the type to float.
This is a matrix of feature vectors.
Each vector contains a list of features.
For an instance,
we'll also want to transform our
class label array into a num py array.
Because a number [inaudible] can easily
be converted into a one hot matrix.
Then we'll return are fully processed
feature matrix and one hot label matrix.
So what is one hot encoding yo DJ dropout.
Bump it.
How was Portland? So I made it. No,
right. I'll put words in like cat, dog,
duck in the lake. If I encode them as
numbers, it's a o k one, two, three, four,
all on display. But if four is more
than one, is Palais more than cat? No,
but I'm not gonna leave it at that because
I'm not trying to rank. Differentiate.
Yeah,
differentiate.
So I'll make each of vector of ones
and those different but not right.
That's just how with go three, no two, no
one hot and code. Yeah. Once we have our
data processed, we'll want to feed
it into our graph. In tensorflow,
the placeholder object is considered the
gateway for data into our computation
graph, so we'll want to
initialize two placeholders,
one for our class labels and one for
our associate in feature vectors.
And when we finally run our training
step using the run function,
we can feed our data into the graph
using the feed dictionary parameter.
The labeled placeholder gets the labels
and the feature place holder gets the
features.
When we run our model,
it'll show the classification line that
it created two separate the meditating
from the non meditating people and
if we feed it a new instance, boom,
it'll classify it just like that.
So to break it down,
the steps to prepare a dataset
are selecting the right data,
processing it and transforming it.
You can easily find public
datasets on the web.
The a number of sources that I'll link
to in the description or you say web
scraping tool, like beautiful
soup to create them yourself.
And once we have our data,
we'll convert them into vectors,
which are numerical representations
that are machine learning model can
understand.
The winner of the make a game bought
challenge is Carl big highs and he created
a bot that used deep cue learning.
His Bot fed the pixel data,
it received to a convolutional neural
net that updated its policy over time
through trial and error.
Also,
this was his first get hub
repo that ass of the week,
and the runner up is Roohan Vermont.
While my Demo Bot couldn't finish a lap,
his could in just two and a half minutes.
The coding challenge for this video
is to write a script that classifies a
Pokemon by their element using a Dataset
that all provide post your get hub,
humbling in the comments, and I'll
announce the winner in the next video.
Please hit that subscribe button. And
for now I've got a decentralize the web,
so thanks for watching.